cette fois-ci, l'usine
d'ozonation va voir le jour à
-des-Prairies.
SÉBASTIEN SAUVÉ, profesntale UdM
- Tous les égouts de Montréalcoe
d'épuration de Rivière-des-
immense cylindre, des puits
plongent près de 50 m pour
collecter les eaux usées.
MAJA VODANOVIC, responsable de
l'eau cortes pluies,
on va traiter jusqu'à 84 m3 par
seconde. Donc, c'e Donc, c'e Dot
l'équivalent de trois stades
olympiques.
tation ne permettent pas
de désinfecter l'eau. On n'y
des résidus de
médicaments, des molécules qui
perturbent le système hormonal,
BENOÎT BARBEAU,directeur, rech.
procédés de traitement des eaux
- Qui sont tous un peu plus
inquiétants les uns que les
évalué que la station
d'épuration sans traitement
actuellement pour les
contaminants émergents relâche 1
d'antibiotiques dans le fleuve
par année.
- La ville octroie à la firme
Pomerleau le premier de huit
site d'ozonation.
MAJA VODANOVIC, re
de l'eau
- C'est le projet
plus significatif des 30
derniè au Québec.
- Le gaz sera éjecté dans ces
deux canaux, juste avant que
- Pour éviter que l'ozone dans
i a pas été en contact
avec l'eau se retrouve dans
l'atmosphère, on doit construire
des gros siphons.
- Un sur chaque canal qui seront
donc hors d'usage chacun leur
tour pendant six mois lors des
deux prochains hivers.
Conséquences : l'usine verra sa
s surverses directement
dans le fleuve sont donc àprévo.
- 35 % des eaux usées, 65 %d'eae
pour des très courtes périces
temps-ci quand il
grandes pluies, on a des
déversements.
être en avance sur son temps,
selon cet expert.
PIERRE JUTEAU,conseiller sc.
épuration des eaux usées
des micros polluants comme
les médiiste
pas présentement au Canada.
Donc, la ville de Montréal va
les normes sont encore à venir.
- Une petite unité pilote qui
trois mois permet d'ajuster le
procédé.
- Comme on monoxyde des
n'en met pas assez, par exemple,
une oxydation
partielle, puis de se retrouver
avec des sous-produits qui
peuvent être plus problématiques
le produit d'origine.
mais aussi d'essais erreurs ont
fait tripler les c
projet pour atteindre 700
millions de dollars. Il sera de
loin le plus important au monde.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio-Canada, Montréal